bonjour ebia venue sir 42
today's video is sponsored by babel the
number one language learning gap
in the world with more than 10 million
subscriptions worldwide
for thousands of years human beings have
fantasized
about immortality which is funny
because for about the same amount of
time people have also been complaining
about how
life is the philosopher's stone the
elixir of life
the fountain of youth these myths all
have
one objective in common to cheat death
and live forever this piece of 16th
century
porn by an artist ironically called
lucas chronic
the elder clearly shows how the
anti-aging process works
at the fountain of youth step one
arrive at the fountain feeling old sick
and decrepid
step two take a skinny dip in the
healing waters
step 3 freak out the other naked girls
by pretending to be a zombie
step 4 emerge from the water looking
youthful
and slightly bored step 5 frolic your
way over to the changing area and get
dressed step 6
go have some lunch with your newly young
pals
and step 7 go shag in the bushes
sounds like fun but this painting isn't
just an
artist's wet dream brought to life it
reflects
genuine popular folklore of the time
in 1535 the spanish colonialist and
historian
oviedo wrote about the conquistador
juan ponce de leon and his search for
the fountain of youth
from there a legend of his quest grew
and captured the imaginations of the
folk back home
and your adventures in foreign lands
will surely capture the imaginations of
folk back home
when you learn a new language with
babble i love travelling in the vast and
beautiful french countryside
but i always get frustrated and feel a
little bit embarrassed
by my total inability to communicate
with the locals
and people in shops and cafes so i'm
using babel to learn to speak french
babble is way better than other language
learning gaps i've used for a start
bubble has no ads which makes it a joy
to use
unlike other apps that use algorithms to
generate lessons
babel lessons are created by real people
who have
vast experience with teaching languages
and
you know what the results speak for
themselves
university studies have shown that just
15 hours of babel
is equal to a semester of college
spanish and that doesn't surprise me
because after just a couple of hours
using babble i've learned and can recall
a long list of french phrases that are
actually useful in conversation
because babel prepares you for
situations you will actually encounter
in real life
the best thing about babel is that the
lessons are actually engaging
and fun unlike other learning methods
that just repeat phrases at you sending
you to sleep
babble lessons are interactive which
keeps my interest for hours
what language have you always wanted to
learn well
you should start today by heading to my
link below to get 65
off a babble subscription for a limited
time only
it's unclear whether ponce de leon
actually was trying to find
the fabled source of eternal life but
his travels took him
to florida where to this day
locals of the town of saint augustine
swear by the magical properties of their
water
and florida does happen to have the
fifth oldest population
of all the u.s states so hey maybe
there's something to it
i'm sure it's nothing to do with all the
rich old people who retire there
of course there are now dozens of water
sources across florida
claimed to be the one true fountain of
youth
even though recent historical evidence
suggests ponce leon
probably never even came there in the
first place my favorite
is the artisan well that produces water
high in
sulfur and radium 226 isotope
radioactive and smells like rotten eggs
make mine a double
though forts of eternal youth might have
swells the minds and cod pieces
of europeans in the 1600s the theme
dates back much further
in the 5th century bc the ancient greek
historian herodotus
told of a fountain in the land of the
microbians in present-day somalia which
gave the locals
extraordinarily long lives and
the alexander romance a semi-fictional
account of the life and conquests of
alexander the great
written in about 338 a.d
tells how the conqueror from macedonia
also went in search of the water of life
on his way to taking over the world
another piece of pulp fiction
the medieval bestseller the travels of
sir john mandeville
also mentioned the fountain of youth
this time locating it at the foot of a
mountain
in southern india personally i would
have put it halfway up the mountain
inside a cave guarded by a really
aggressive goat
but i guess that's why i was never asked
to be dungeon master
in a similar vein stories of the elixir
of life
some kind of magical potion that will
grant the drinker
immortality or eternal youth can be
found in world cultures
from east to west the earliest recorded
reference dates to before 2000 bc
in scripts that would eventually become
the epic of gilgamesh now you only have
to turn on a television or surf the net
to realize
we haven't evolved that much in our
thinking since then
everywhere you look someone seems to
have found the magic cure for aging
snail syrup peruvian frog juice
facials made of blood air yoga
cryogenic cooling acid that peels off
your skin
there's an endless list of things people
are willing to try to hold on to their
youth
and it's big business the longevity
economy is estimated to be worth more
than
7.6 trillion dollars a year
but before you click buy now on that ad
for fermented yags vomit
you might be interested to know there
are areas of the world
where people appear to have already
solved the riddle of long life in
these pockets of civilization called
blue zones
a higher than usual number of people
live much longer
than average these are regions where we
find
unusually high concentrations of
centenarians
people 100 years old or more and
super centenarians people over 110
who wear capes the term blue zone
sounds like it should mean something
important but its origin is actually a
little underwhelming
it was coined by two gerontologists yes
that really is a name for people who
study aging
gianna pess and michelle puller they
were the first to identify that the
population of sardinia's
neuro province included the highest
number of male centenarians
in the world as they studied the cluster
of villages with the highest longevity
they drew concentric blue circles to
highlight the relevant area
and called everything inside the blue
zone
so really we could just as easily today
be talking about
the purple zone or the pus zone
or even the yellow highlighter because
my bloody kid stole my pen again zone
oh and i should point out that blue
zones bear no relation to the blue
period which was when picasso seems to
have had a paint shortage for about
three years
at the start of the 1900s pez and pulan
were joined in their research by
explorer and national geographic fellow
dan buettner who helped expand the use
of the term to identify longevity
hotspots around the world
in total there are five blue zones where
inhabitants live abnormally long
and healthy lives the islands of okinawa
in japan
sardinia in italy the nakoya peninsula
in costa rica i carrier in greece
and the community of seventh-day
adventists who live in loma linda
in california for decades we've been
trying to uncover the secrets to living
a long and happy life but it's
surprisingly difficult
to identify shared behaviors or
qualities amongst the world's oldest of
fogies
quite inconveniently the oldest
individuals have tended to vary
significantly
in their approach to living some never
touched a cigarette
others puffed like chimneys well into
their hundreds
some never drank alcohol others loved
the tipple
one swore by sushi another ate
two raw eggs a day but in focusing on
communities that consistently broke the
age bank
the blue zones project revealed
longevity patterns that were common to
regions rather than individuals and it's
about more than
just life spans blue zone areas also
present
high healthy life expectancy where
people consistently reach their 90s
with low rates of chronic disease blues
owners don't just
live longer they do so with more energy
better health and all the other stuff
that makes them fun to have at parties
in their research brettner and his team
identified nine lessons that can be
learnt from blue's own lifestyles
but these can be summed up into four
main habits
the first is moderate but regular
physical activity
this is not the same as sitting at a
desk all day then running yourself
ragged at the gym for an hour
in okinawa japan home to the world's
longest living women
people traditionally sit on the floor to
eat
talk work or relax okanawan centenarians
sit down on the floor and get up again
dozens or hundreds of times per day
which exercises their legs back and core
in a natural way and in sardinia where
we find the world's longest living
men the longevity phenomenon is
especially concentrated amongst
shepherds
who spend their days outside walking
over steep
and rugged terrain in the blue zones
region
of vicaria greece more than 80 percent
of people between ages 65 and 100
are having viagra free sex a little bit
of geriatric house your father
isn't just a sign of good vitality it
also keeps your vitals healthy
a study published in the british journal
of medicine tracked 1 000
45 to 59 year old welshman for 10 years
with researchers finding that men who
experience frequent orgasms
had half the coronary heart disease
mortality risk of their
less orgasmic counterparts and
a longitudinal study of 1500 americans
had similar good news for frisky women
too
finding that for middle aged married
women
more regular orgasms lowered mortality
risk
the second magic ingredient is a strong
family and social support system
okinawa is sometimes called the island
of the immortals
because more than 1 000 people in the
last 40 years
have lived 100 years or more there
critical to this longevity is a
tradition of wise
local groups for support and
companionship
between residents that can last for
decades
traditionally children are placed in
small groups
moais to socialize and grow together
as they get older these moais continue
to meet
work and hang out together some have
lasted more than 90 years
amongst a loma linda community in the
united states
volunteering social care and strong
face-to-face relationships
are fundamental to their way of living
societal cohesion
is also helped by the fact that everyone
is a seventh-day adventist
so they're all singing off the same hymn
sheet literally
the value of close relationships has
also been confirmed in numerous other
studies
a meta-analysis of 148 longitudinal
studies involving more than 300
000 participants reveals that older
people with strong social relationships
are 50 percent more likely to live
longer than those who are isolated
or lonely if you have regular contact
with friends
family and neighbors the longevity
benefit is similar to quitting smoking
and about twice as beneficial as
exercising regularly
or maintaining a normal weight emma
morano
would have disagreed though she was an
italian super centenarian
who before her death at the age of 117
years and 137 days
declared that the secrets to her long
life
was staying single talk about playing
hard to get
the third blue zone secret is to live
with purpose
to have a reason to get out of bed in
the morning
in okinawa they call this your icky guy
and in nicoya costa rica they call it
plan de veda
but having a clear idea of why you're
alive
is an integral part of all the blue's
own cultures
so yeah if you're a nihilist you're
basically screwed
in an 11 year nih funded study
looking at the correlation between
having a sense of purpose
and longevity healthy people between the
ages of 65 and
92 who expressed having clear goals or
purpose lived longer and lived
better than those who did not according
to dr
makota suzuki of the okinawa research
center for longevity science
an ichigai or purpose doesn't need to be
a grand vision
it can be something as simple as a
dedication to a hobby
or a commitment to caring for someone
else let's hope
making youtube videos counts because i'm
planning on living to 142
at least the last big blue zone tip
is to set up your life and environment
so that the healthy choice
is the easy choice not just an option
this applies to all aspects of lifestyle
but especially diet
and physical exercise in blue zones
meals are created according to
old recipes and eating is a social event
with most diets largely plant-based and
high in vegetables
whole grains pulses and nuts those that
do
eat fish or other meat only consume
small amounts
on average about five times a month
alcohol
if consumed is also taken in moderation
and
none of the blue zones have fast food
restaurants which
eliminates the temptation to make poor
food choices
sadly for those of you looking for some
secret diet or geriatric
life hack blue zone studies show there
is no one big trick to living a long and
healthy life
blues owners have such impressive
longevity because they combine a bunch
of mutually supporting factors
that help them to do the right things
long enough
and avoid doing the wrong things long
enough
to lower the risk of developing chronic
diseases
and according to bueno these little
pockets of unusually long-lived people
might not last much longer because
most of the blue zones and potential
blue zones identified so far
won't exist in 10 years time due to
the anticipated influence of what he
calls
the standard american diet curse you
delicious burgers
having said all that there could be
another explanation for these strange
blue zones
and one that might conceivably be called
a hack
a non-peer-reviewed paper published in
drew a lot of attention for suggesting
subjects in blue zone studies often had
no proof of age
or used fake documents the publication
also theorized that because three of the
five blue zone regions are in areas of
relative poverty
subjects were motivated to lie about
their age
and falsify documents for pension
benefits
and that documents proving age were more
likely to be wrong
because public services in poor areas
are generally badly managed
so yeah if you want to live to 200 all
you have to do is get really good at
forging government documents so you can
change the birth date on your passport
in response to the paper dan buettner
provided detailed explanations of the
age verification processes
followed in the blue zone field studies
and it has to be said
such widespread fraud seems extremely
unlikely
he also rejected the idea that the
relative poverty
of some blue zone areas affected the
accuracy of the research
pointing out that public services in
those areas were excellent
and that it was exactly the lack of
first world convenience
that helped people stay active and have
better diets
these kinds of questions about blue zone
data are mirrored in
another perhaps even bigger age-related
controversy
gene calment a french woman who died in
at the age of 122 years and 164 days
is universally regarded as the oldest
human
to ever have lived she was born before
the invention of moving pictures or the
telephone
she watched the eiffel tower being built
she even met vincent van gogh
and yet at the time she was born
the life expectancy for a french woman
was 45.
unsurprisingly in later life she became
a supercentenarian celebrity
and was studied by numerous
gerontologists trying to unlock the
secrets of long life
but a couple of years ago russian
mathematician nicola isaac
published a paper calling calment a fake
to see why he was skeptical about
kalman's real age all you have to do
is take a quick look at a list of the
oldest people
ever to have lived because in the game
of life
well long life gene calment
is winning by a mile zak claims the real
gene carmen
actually died in 1934 and that
her daughter yvonne assumed her identity
to avoid taxes which would mean she
wasn't even a century old when she died
in 1997 loser there's no denying
calment is a real statistical anomaly
but the vast majority of gerontologists
agree
zack's evidence is weak and that the
immense amount of scrutiny and analysis
calment was subjected to in her lifetime
would have revealed any dodginess in her
story
but the mathematician's challenge is
taken seriously
because it impacts our understanding
of how long humans can live and
therefore how we should live and
there is no shortage of conflict in this
domain
recent years have seen massive
advancements in the understanding of the
aging process
with much of the research backed by
billionaires in silicon valley
scientist and author of ending ageing
aubrey de gray
is perhaps most well known for his work
on
strategies to exclude death
from our genes his goal is immortality
and many of his peers believe the first
person who will live beyond 1000
is already alive today but there's also
strong evidence to suggest
the maximum lifespan of humans is fixed
and subject to non-negotiable natural
constraints
and some scientists suggest that whilst
we may find ways to live
slightly longer better and disease-free
lives
biologically our lifespans are capped
if they're correct then the lessons we
can learn in the blue zones
are even more important either way the
future will reveal which side wins
we just need to live long enough to see
it thanks for watching